今日はこちらスティカフェんです
私は非常に長いが日本語のビデオはやってないんで申し訳ないんです
皆さんどういうテーマに対して興味があるのか知りませんけれども
いつでももし何か希望があったら教えてください
この間ですねえ
英語の方のビデオ
見た人をからですね
要望がありましてね
というのは私がどういう風にして中国語を習ったのか教えてくださいというのがこの
ある人から様の注文っていうか質問が来たんですよ
それでは僕それについて英文のビデオもやったんですけれどもそれじゃあこのテーマで
また日本語で利用
やろうと思っていますまずあの
存知かどうか知りませんけども私が日本語を勉強する前に中国語を勉強しました
というのは日本に着いた時にですね
中55のいわゆる感じはあのー
をも読みました
すでー
でそれはもちろん私の日本語の勉強に対して大変
あのためになりました
それでそれいつ勉強したのかというとそれは1968
1967年ですねん
私がカナダの勝負のいわゆる
まあこれはのいえば
外交官としてのその消費勝負に入ったわけですね
で体はその当時中国とその外交関係を
結ぶその準備引田あるわけですよねそのためにやはり勝負の方でも中国語のできる人を
育たなく育てなければならないということで
発表があったんですよで僕はイエスじゃあ
すぐその中国語を勉強し始めたんです
何もその牡丹はでですねこれは確かに台湾の大使館の
そのいわゆる先生から勉強したんですけれどあまり役に立たなかったけれどもそれが一
つのま
いわゆる私の音振動を見せる意味ではですね
偉業に性がありましてはたちがその任命されまして彼女部の初のそのに中国語の
いわゆる
勉強する人に
選ばれましたということで香港行っちゃったんですね
遊ぶでいろんな外交官はね中国語勉強中なんですよ
それはあの日本人も含めてある英国人アメリたち
その当時はですねー
確かに彼等ちょっと攻撃だと思いますがその後日本で有名な
政治家になった人がですね外交官で
その中国を僕と一緒に中国を勉強したんですよ
でじゃあどういう風に勉強したのかというとまずは崎の霧を見ている方であればですね
私がいわゆる日本語で言うたドクター長束とた語多読多聴の卑怯さなんですよ
言葉を勉強するにはですねまずたくさん読んでたくさん
聞いてそのたくさんの合意をもう自分の声を増やしていってですね
その器具においてその言葉に馴染んだりあるいは
気楽に諸説でも読めるようになればそれだけ豊富にですね
自分の頭脳ですね刺激すれば
ジュノーはいろんなものを自分なりに整理します
だからあえていろんな速雑な分布のルールを勉強しなくても頭脳は自動的に自然的に
勉強できるわけです
もちろんあの文法のいろんなルール読んでもいいんですよそれは
え
役に立たないわけじゃないんですけれども
やはりたくさんのそういう言葉とのケーキがないとその分ぽのボールが非常に消化しに
くるわけですよ
で中国語を勉強した時ですねそれはだから1968年
それはれ
香港ブース nua 者カーリー
スターまあわーシニアすぐ会う
というところで勉強したんですよ毎日確かに3時間あるいは始めた時にですね1日5
時間の一対一お姉さんがたんですよ
それは僕にとっている多すぎるんで疲れますからそれを減らしてどっちかというと自分
なりに
家で毎日56時間がな時間も聞いたり読んだり
練習したわけですよ
でまず1本目の本は
そしてテープがねそれがあの感じ使わなくていわゆるあの当時のピンインですねピン出
なかったけれども
もう一つのロマ g ウェーブじゃあユーロマイリーのシステムを使って
それがまぁ最初聞いた時は非常に速くてそれからもうわざと
早すぎたその速でで速度で録音されたんじゃないかとみんなもう
覚えたわけですけれどもしかし所有音何株なんかも聞いてですね
そのスピードにもんなぁだんだんと慣れてきたわけですよ
その次にですねやはりも読み始めた理由
あの
まず漢字を勉強するにはん
やはり書くしかないですよねて0だからあのある環境ですねまぁ十戒かいてそしてこの
あの
v 盤の麺のような紙技ですね
2列の右のほうにいこっ君ををっブーブーまたこのまま第3あるいは発毛シネム気の4
エヌフォーんんんまきましたティというのはです
ねえ
いくつかの漢字を書いた後ですね最初の火事
またぶつかるんですよぶつかったらまた
を忘れないうちにまた書かないといけないった
それの繰り返し食いたいしそれで最初はですね一日二部感じ
やってああ
一番ピークの時に毎日3時間子もああいうふうに
習ってですねならて散ってももう
ロブはになら針に燃えたは知られるけれどもまた同じことでまた勉強したつもりの感じ
はもう一度勉強するということでですね毎日だったわけですよ
それでだいたい1年に
まあ
そうですねあ
3000ないし4前漢字を勉強したと思うんですよね
そして感じが勉強するときにですねやはりそれを使う
特に読む
ようなことも大事なんでまずファニーなキュージョン chinese star 2
分ワーカーフィーチャー
hoh 中央区の rb 以下あああああこれはティフォンへ一アロ09:00
ないの
あの出版物ですけれども
そこにですね本物中国の歴史
20世紀の歴史へ
1911年の奥さんをいわゆる
国民革命のいろんな出来事
あるいは有名なサッカーのものがここに入ってたんですよ
そしてそう言うと同時にその中国語のメインの五割パターンですよね
助産に上階いくつですあの
それがその複雑なルールじゃあいいなぁあルールの説明があってけれども私は及ぼしし
たんですよ
基本はパターンですよねだからもう中国の基本のパターン
動いてぐらいウラーあるか知りませんけども
それをもう中心にですねそのパターンを
どっちかというと思う
身につけたんですよねそしてその後はねぇもう他の生徒よりもたくさん読んだ
例えば高齢らの方はですねであの当時はすべて鯉本には
文字合意表はついているわけですよというなぜかというと
中国の中国の事象を調べれば良いものにてまた買う
そして
秘書の辞書を調べるとですねすぐはせますから
だからそういうような僕はいいとにかく面白い本で合意表のついている者を
それは文化であろうなあのー
文学であろうが歴史てやろうがあるいはその
あの鳥の協賛共産党とか毛沢東が書いたものとか
その他の共産党 no リヤたちがいくつかの段階でねニ十世紀の歴史において帰っ
たりいろんな文章
まあ選んだわけないんですよそして籠城もネイルうシーンもあの巫女ましたし
それからですねだいたい始まってですね中国語はいました
そうですね7ヶ月7カ月後ですね
初めて合意票についてない本読んだんですよこれは
落とし anza これはがオフは有名な中国のサッカーの
これはノンというふうに日本語でやってるか知りませんけども
これは北京にを行われている非常に有名な話なんですよ
それは最初の僕らは読んだ本な家を小説
それは非常にもう一つのもう
もう富士山を登ったんや波みたいな感じでね
非常にそれで自信がついたんですよもちろん読んだときに
a 波
4万家事は分からなかったし
そして意味もねぇどうでしょう7はにしか湧かなかったんですよただ
だいたいついていったんですよしかし辞書調べないん
それであのーそうですねまぁその後ですね
あの
中国語するテーマ
雷国間の試験を受けて感謝しましたけれども
他の生徒はもっと時間区の実際のクラスでですね
先生と
使ったわけですけども僕が飛距離よりも自分でいわゆる
多読多聴読んで聴いてそして私の合意はですね
その他のせいてるぞ
運とは豊富
で面白いでるでしょあの声が豊富なってくるんですね
もっと面白いものを読めるわけですよでもっと面白いものを読めると5位はもっと豊富
な
だからその角2丁というのは
一番背の言葉の弁慶の近道
もちろん
あの
話できるときは話ししないといけないといけませんけれども
合意があると思い広い話していきます
合意が非常に支えられているとあまり大した話できない
だからその他取った今日ですその号はですねあのー
はた平根器具の夏いわゆる多読はもう読むでしょ
例えば中国歴史の本とか中国の文化についての
その他読めますけどねえ
毛沢東のこれあまり面白くないけども読みますが
ピクルも大事で今中国もし中国2石をの
何が聞きたいならものすごい豊富にあるんですよ
日本でそのいわゆる
アウディを僕といいか
you say
所小説書籍しれませんけど
少ないんですよ中国ものすごいだから現代現代小説は少ないけれどもあの
今後まあ
forever
もういろんなものを例えば者6社これはもう
コメリですよね5と2冊バラエティは非常に豊富で
だから僕は今の中国語は全バラ北京語は多分
試験を受けた時よりも貼っ僕はリュウちゃんでしょそれはもう処理ラインもにょんで
聞いてそれもちろんすごい
中国に住んだことはないんですけどもこちらはいくうえで中国人と会ったりするときに
彼らずさっぺきんぐを使いますまあそういうわけで私の中国語を習った
井筒化の背景についてのまあ説明
何がいこれについてあるいは他の何かに対して質問あったらぜひ
聞いてくださいじゃどうもありがとうすすめします